a lot of people are angry about Shan
Spicer's cameo on last night's Emmys
people are mad about that yeah a lot of
talk on the internet today people are
angry mm-hmm they're also not thrilled
to hear that Attorney General Jeff
Sessions will be hosting the Latin
Grammys that not happy about that he's
out there he's big which one is this
Andy which one is that I forget don't
know no the big winner at last night's
Emmys was The Handmaid's Tale yeah
that's a that's a show about a
repressive society where women have no
rights yeah that's right it won best
writing best drama and best Mike Pence
fantasy so big how are we doing on the
show people aren't sure about that we
were so close to that award - in Spanish
yeah I know we just missed it just
missed it today in New York President
Trump spoke before the United Nations
General Assembly he's addressed them
yeah there was kind of an awkward moment
when Trump look into the audience and
said how the hell did you people get
into this country
I want you out of here get out over the
weekend President Trump retweeted a gif
of himself
knocking Hillary Clinton down with a
golf ball yeah yeah a response Hillary
retweeted a gift whereas she beat Trump
by three million votes
that's one of those ones where backstage
were like they won't laugh but they'll
clap did they last not really they
didn't
we prefer laughter but every now and
then we like the charity organization
Oxfam is renting out president Trump's
childhood home
to refugees it's pretty cool they've
already rented out a room to a refugee
on the run named Melania that's a great
impression you'll see else is going on
but got some good news for California
California Governor Jerry Brown is
working on a plan to build to kind of
two tunnels that will bring water to
Southern California yeah yeah now it's
California so one tunnels for flat water
the other sparkling with lime
that one got some laughter then applause
[Laughter]
it's a crazy one the wife of Donald
Trump's listen to this the wife of
Donald Trump's Ethics adviser was caught
having sex in a car with the prison
inmate can you believe that Donald Trump
has an ethics adviser
and I like to end on an international
story in Germany a man very shy people
in Germany a man working out at a gym
got his penis caught in a five-pound
weight now in fairness on Fridays he
does legs back in penis that's
[Applause]
german word for penis what is the german
word for penis sir that's no fun
that's no fun it's like it's the same at
for me I want it to be something like
Heights and zhaozhou that's more fun
what's the point what's the point of
just using the same word you should make
up so is everything the same word over
in Germany I did go there I didn't
wasn't asking a lot about penises
I want that man removed
you